- I love this movie, so
I have to start with it.
Is it true that you were almost
Star-Lord in Guardians of
the Galaxy? - Well,
- [Kelly] I can't see
you. I'm just saying,
like I thought that was amazing.
I could see you doing that.
- I don't know for sure.
This is based on, well, yes,
yes, it is true. Sorry. It is.
- [Kelly] Okay Yeah, humble pie, whatever.
I'd brag all day about that.
- [Glenn] Feels weird.
Cause it's like, well,
how close was I really? But I
what happened was I auditioned
- I heard it was between
you and Chris Pratt.
- [Glenn] We'll see.
That's what I heard too.
- [Kelly] Exactly.
- Yeah, yeah
- [Kelly] I would flag that
card everywhere. (laughter)
- That's so cool.
- Yeah I mean, it was, I
went and auditioned for it.
Like, I think a lot of actors did,
and I had no idea how close I got. I,
I walked out of there and I
was like, yeah, it went okay.
But actually, as I was walking
out of the waiting room,
I saw Chris Pratt and I
remember thinking, oh,
he's perfect for this.
- [Kelly] Oh, really?
- Yeah, totally cause I think he's great.
And I was like, oh, he's perfect
for this. And I was like,
there's no way I'm getting
it. And then I didn't.
And then, (laughter)
- Which kind. Of sucks. It's so awesome.
- [Glenn] Yeah. It would
have been fun, but then,
I don't know, like when
the movie came out,
James Gunn did some
interview and somebody,
I guess he said that I was
his second choice in the
interview, but no one ever told me,
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- [Glenn] So I had no idea how close
- [Kelly] That's information
I would want to know?
- [Glenn] Yeah
- [Kelly] Or maybe you
don't, if you're that close,
here's the thing I do,
I do think things find where
they're supposed to be.
Like, I feel like that was songs too.
Like I've been sent songs, I'm
like this isn't right for me.
And then they sent it to an
artist that I'm like, ah,
that's who that was for. And
they're successful with it.
Like, and it's, I think
that that happens a lot.